Oh, okay, it works.
It's like, is my... is my mic on?
Hello?
Can you hear me?
This is for you, Lilac.
Thank you.
Hello, everybody.
I'm... mint... ish.
I'm mint... ish.
Lilac Mint-chan.
I'm mint.
Hello, hello, hello.
I'm back.
Yeah!
Hello.
Welcome.
Welcome, welcome.
What you...
Groon?
Gran?
You're way cuter than mint is...
Hey, wait a second.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Huh?
You don't mean that, right?
So true.
True!
It's... it's literally me!
And you're gonna say that?
What are you talking about?
It's literally me!
You can't just... you can't... you can't just...
You can't just go around to other...
Ghostmates and say that they're cuter.
You can't just do that.
That was a typo.
I'm seething.
Wait to reuse my art.
Thank you!
Thank you for the art!
Let's go back.
So we fit the thumbnail.
Last time I used a... I used a Gothamint... Gothamint...
Thumbnail, I was... I was...
It was false advertising, so...
Thank you, mint was cuter.
Truly an upgrade.
Stop!
You would say that.
You're just like purple.
Need all those things to be pink.
You're just so white purple.
It's mint with hair dye.
Anyways, guys, welcome to... to Grun?
Grun?
Not quite sure how it's pronounced.
That is fair.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
What if we love both versions?
Then it's a perfect balance.
You have to love the original, like, 1% more.
But this is a Dutch game.
So how's the music?
I hope it's not too loud.
I kind of like it.
It's kind of a vibe.
But maybe... Maybe I should go to the audio.
Maybe it's a little bit down.
Oh, a sound effect.
Actually, hold on.
Let's do that.
Let's reduce loud sounds.
That's some fantastic news.
I finally paid off all my student loans.
So take the rest of my money and keep being the best StinkyKo's fan you can be.
Oh my gosh!
Solid as sky!
Congratulations!
Congrats!
You did it!
You're free!
I hope you enjoy the game.
Thank you.
Oh, there's only a few endings.
We'll see how long we play.
How long it takes us to get whatever endings there are.
Leave.
There we go.
Freedom!
Oh my gosh.
I remember... Only because of Vtubing I was able to...
I remember when I was able to pay off my ghost student loans.
I was like, wow.
I only have you guys to thank.
Hell yeah, LilacStream.
Hell no, RiceNat in chat.
This is a vinyl guy.
Yes, I got it!
I'm looking... I can look at it right now.
Thank you!
Actually, I have a... I got a record player too.
I just have to set it up.
I haven't set it up yet.
ADK.
Oh gosh.
Good luck.
But I didn't have so much.
I had a couple scholarships.
I was able to go to school early.
My college wasn't so expensive.
Luckily, I didn't have too much.
Inside everyone, there's two mints.
Mint and purple mint.
You could say I have a big brain.
You could say my brain is massive.
You could say I'm a smarty pants.
Let's start.
Purple guy?
Is there... wait.
Oh, E to get up.
Oh, there it is.
I'm on the bus.
I got a coin.
Always check for your belongings and others as well.
I just saw that you will be at AWA.
I will!
I will.
And that's not the only thing either.
So keep on the lookout for more.
Yeah.
I have a scholarly question.
What do you call boobies?
Paranormal entities?
That's so smart.
That's a good one.
Nerd.
Shut the hell up.
Are you not feeling well, mint?
I don't know why my voice is so icky today.
Simlish.
Can not make out what he's saying.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I was ordering...
I was ordering food earlier.
I like called to place an order, which is like huge for me.
But I really wanted this specific food.
And the place also had like a cucumber salad.
And I was like...
I watched actually like a TikTok this morning about a guy that made a cucumber salad.
I'm craving some cucumber salad.
And so I asked...
I was like...
What's in the...
What's in the cucumber salad?
And he was like...
You got the...
And you got the...
And I was like...
I think I'll stick with the fried rice.
I was like...
I couldn't understand what he said.
He was like...
You got the...
And I was like...
It's okay.
I'll just get what I ordered.
So...
This moment literally happened to me today.
Wow.
Home.
Sweet home.
It's beautiful here.
These roses were planted 60 years ago.
Hag.
Old.
A bridge key.
I don't know what that could be.
Oh.
For the bridge.
Thick.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
Can we swim?
Not quite.
Sorry that my voice is very strange today.
Need a watering can.
Okay.
So we're just a gardener, guys.
Look at us.
Wow.
It's so beautiful.
I heard a loud crack behind me.
What was that?
Plank.
Press tab to view sound for Polaroids.
1 out of 42?
Okay.
We can't leave.
Wait, does that mean...
Just jump.
Wait, there's a guy over there.
And there's a thing there.
Okay.
Garden.
We got the shed.
Why does it say 1B?
You need a trowel for this.
Okay.
It is a pretty looking pot.
So I saw someone, a streamer that I like, playing this.
I didn't watch too much because it was interesting, so I wanted to play it myself.
But then as I was watching the guy playing it, Matara messaged me.
And she was like, this looks like a game that you would like.
And I was like, I think it's Destiny.
I have to play this.
2B's older sister.
Inspect.
Toilet.
It is an abandoned nest.
But it is...
A little bit spooky, I think.
What's going on here?
What was happening?
I don't think I should...
I think I absorbed it?
Alien abduction?
Maybe?
I think maybe I'm possessed now.
Oh my goodness.
You solved the Polaroid.
Oh, is this the shed?
So the Polaroids, you have to go to these places.
Obtained shears.
Press left mouse button to use the tool.
To do, cut the grass, trim all hedges, water the flowers, get rid of molehills, clear all trash.
Why is it...
Creaking and cracking like that.
Oh, we got the toilet key.
And then there's like... You guys are kind of blocking it, but there's like...
Okay.
What the hell is this?
Oh.
Dear gardener, please make sure my garden is presentable by Monday.
What day is it?
You are not allowed... Oh, sorry.
You are allowed to take the shears, trowel, and watering can from this shed.
But please note that my house is off limits.
I would also advise you not to wander off during the night.
It gets cold and foggy up here in the north.
It is possible that I require your assistance in something other than the garden later this weekend.
In that case, I will contact you through the phone in the corner.
I expect you are up to the task.
Kind regards, F.H.
Postman.
Postman nuts.
Nobody is answering.
Oh, okay.
This is my bed.
It's too early to sleep.
We're not gonna...
Sleep is for the weak.
I'm a gardener.
Oh my gosh, it's kind of really satisfying.
I feel like there would be a much more efficient way to cutting...
than...
with the shears.
Like, how about we invest in technology...
What's this?
I missed one.
Magpie!
We saw that.
My favorite streamer, Lilac Phantom.
Beware the mulch?
The mulch.
Rin, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Magpie.
Oh, why is it telling me to run?
I don't like that.
Wait, it was a...
Where was the bird's nest?
Oh, over here.
Okay, so we need to get a magpie.
Oh, ow!
I'm kind of blocking it here.
Let me...
Let me move over just a tad.
Because there's like a percentage.
Let me...
Let me scoot you guys down as well.
Oh, it does say Saturday.
So you guys can see the time.
Give me a second.
Scoot you guys down a little.
And we'll do like that maybe.
Hopefully it's not too intrusive.
Beware the mulch.
Oh yeah, wait, hold on.
Let me actually scoot you guys up a little bit now.
Perfect!
Awesome!
What a big old grass plant.
Are these the molehills then maybe?
This is probably AM.
I imagine it'll probably do 24 hour time.
You need a watering can.
Oh, I was looking at the cemetery.
How mysterious.
There's another place to hide in.
It's right next to a cemetery.
I bet she won't beat the game.
What the hell Doki?
Did you play this?
Oh, trim the hedges.
Let's go!
I'm at 20% already Doki.
I'm like way ahead of you.
Look at this.
Oh, there's garbage here.
Clean.
Look, I'm like doing way better job than you ever could.
Sometimes I can't tell if the grass is long or not.
Thanks for the really awesome streams.
Thank you Hanna!
Thank you.
Oh, it's locked.
Do I need a watering can?
Well, she said the watering can was in the shed.
But...
It's definitely not in here.
Let's just keep cutting.
We'll go into the bathroom once I'm finished cutting, okay?
And then also the trowel.
You hear the scream of a magpie.
I solved the Polaroid.
There's another one!
Oh my gosh, so when you solve a Polaroid, you get another Polaroid.
Good luck!
Thank you!
Rotten plank.
I guess it wasn't abandoned.
Wait, what is that?
How did he do that?
June 21st, 2001.
Today I made quite some progress on the garden.
At the end of the day, I even got time to explore other parts of town.
Tomorrow I will do something about those dead flowers.
While I think of it, I probably left the watering can in the park.
I should not forget to retrieve that in the morning.
And it is also time to fix that rotten plank in the fence to the backyard.
But for now, I have to head to bed.
It is getting quite dark.
This one?
I see it!
Demolish!
Okay, I am vandalizing my place of work.
That's fine.
Don't worry about it, everybody.
Actually, I can't tell what this place needs.
He said the house was not...
He said the house was off limits, you know.
What is this?
Oh, I got a hammer.
Is that blood?
Press Q to cycle through tools.
Okay, interesting.
That's not blood.
Why is it... Why don't I need to tend to the...
Oh wait, maybe I do.
Maybe I was actually cutting it, but I couldn't tell.
Oh, it is a little...
You sense that you do not have to cut the grass here.
I don't care what you tell me right now.
I'm a gardener.
It's my destiny to cut the grass.
Okay.
We have several things.
We first have to cut the grass.
Then, we have to...
Go to the bathroom.
Order of operations, everybody.
It was cutting it, just a little tiny bit, I think.
Is this grass also?
Yeah.
Everything gets cut.
What about these tiny little weeds?
And this grass.
Okay.
All grass gets cut.
If it's grass, it gets cut.
Do I have to go to the potty now?
Hold!
Hold.
You must be strong.
Your gardener instinct will carry you through.
Only 34% done!
Wait a second.
Oh, maybe it also includes like...
The other activities that we must do.
Oh, oh wait.
Oh, never mind.
This place is just...
It is a normal garden gnome.
Wait.
Look, the grass is all shiny here again.
Can I go through?
Oh, it's locked.
The car!
We did that.
We did that one already though.
This place is so overgrown.
Has no one tended to it in like 50 years?
What happened?
He looks just like you?
I hear a sound.
It's like a...
Just like a crabby.
Okay, this place is actually ginormous.
We have to cut all of this?
In just a few days?
Okay.
One giant blade of grass.
Like I said, maybe we should really invest in a...
An automated lawnmower?
Or...
Anything else?
To make this process...
Less demanding?
Is it him?
Is he speaking to me?
Sorry, sir.
I'm above your pay.
Cut that grass like a pro.
I'm a pro!
I'm a pro at cutting grass.
I'm a pro.
Oh, I left one hedge.
I'm so sorry.
For all you freaks out there being like, One single hedge, please!
There's stuff behind the shed.
I feel like this game is gonna be a lot of...
Roaming...
I found a coin!
Dang it, I thought that was...
I know he said something about the...
The watering can being in the park, but for a moment I thought that was it.
Cut the hedge!
Oh, I missed one.
If you see me missing any...
Little bits, just say...
Cut the hedge.
Oh!
I cut all the grass!
Uh, no I did not.
Excuse me?
What are my standards?
Poopy?
Like, no!
There's literal...
Giant blades.
Okay, let's go back...
To the car.
And then to the bathroom.
I guess it's very forgiving in case you...
Uh...
Okay, I thought it would give me a Polaroid, but nevermind.
Am I gonna have to whack someone?
Am I gonna have to kill?
Am I a gardener and a murderer?
Oh, an empty plate.
Okay.
And I'm a chef.
Living car!
Thanks for the gift!
The house is off limits.
Yes, sir.
Okay, bathroom.
Oops.
Uh...
Wow!
I just noticed like the tippy top of the church and everything.
This game has like such a...
Cute style.
I like it.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, what?
I don't quite like this ambiance.
Why is there...
I cleared all the trash!
Why is this like a public restroom?
This is not...
You do not see anything in the mirror.
Not even myself?
Am I a vampire?
Garden dome.
What does he have?
What are his secrets?
Wait a second.
Do I?
Oh my god!
I'm a murderer?
Gas?
Gas station?
Oh, and I found a coin.
Nice.
Alright, so we cut all the grass.
We picked up all the trash.
Now we need to get out of here.
I suppose.
But...
Our gates are locked, so the only option is going inside the house, I think.
Sorry, sir.
I must enter.
Because...
I have no other option.
What's this?
There is a strange smell coming from this drain.
Garden key.
This tap is dripping a bit.
Did you see it?
Did you see that guy?
Why was he so tall?
It's starting to get dark.
The church.
Oh my gosh, and then it says 0% complete.
This area could also use some gardening.
Was I not supposed to cut that?
Wait.
That was really ominous.
Okay, don't touch those flowers.
Oh my gosh.
I'll spit.
Thank you so much.
Evil purple Scottish Minto.
Please spit on us.
It is a tombstone.
Here lies...
My career.
I know it said not to stay out after dark, but what if I just keep gardening?
What else is around here?
The bridge to the park is under construction.
And how late is night anyway, right?
Like...
This area right here.
A paddle.
You need a paddle.
I need a paddle to steer this.
I've also noticed there was a D and there's an O over there.
You cannot see the bottom.
Yes, I can.
They're right above me.
You get it, chat?
I just called you a button.
The owls are hooting and hollering.
What's going to happen if I stay out anyway?
No one's here to... My mom's not here to tell me to stop doing work.
You show that overgrown garden who's boss, boss.
Oh, something jumped out of the grass.
A...
Doorknob.
Did we see a door with no handle?
I don't remember seeing one.
It's getting late.
It's only...
It's not even 9 PM.
The sun is still up.
Guys, I only have a couple of days.
I've got to get this done.
Oh, wait.
One hour?
What am I?
Lazy bones over here?
Panbeon's really...
Just shifted, huh?
If a ghost, a demon...
If a monster, if anyone is trying to get me...
They're gonna see that I'm doing a really great job.
And be like...
I really shouldn't bother that guy.
He's like...
Doing such a great job.
You know?
That's all I have to say about that.
What was that?
What was that sound?
Maybe I should go back.
Alright.
It's getting dark.
Nah.
The sun is still up.
It's still pink.
I'm just...
It's just the ambiance, you know?
It's fine.
It's...
Nevermind.
It's not fine.
I
know.
Ok, stop working.
What happened?
Who are you?
Time to sleep.
I'm sorry.
I was out too late.
Who was at my door?
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
Everything is fine.
The grunt.
Ok, don't cut these guys.
It makes...
It makes them angry.
Is it because I cut the flout?
What do you think?
I love the doves.
The little dove sounds.
Anyway.
Does anyone else live here?
Like...
So we need to get to the park to get the...
The... What is it called?
The watering can.
Church door at midnight.
Alright guys.
You know what we must...
If only I had seen that soda.
I could have stayed.
I'm just gonna pretend that it didn't show up until after I went to sleep.
Or something.
I'm just gonna pretend it just showed up.
Ah yeah.
Little sleepy game.
See guys, this is so relaxing.
Isn't this so nice?
They are just gardening and...
Everything is normal.
The grass doesn't grow back I think.
This one didn't have a door handle.
What is this?
High voltage.
I got more grass to cut.
Why does the church look like that?
It's Sunday.
Shouldn't it be full of people?
Shouldn't it be like bustling?
Everyone is like, yep, I'm at church.
Okay.
Still hasn't told me that I cut all the grass.
Is there that much more?
Am I missing an area?
Oh, there is actually quite a bit down here.
Oh, oh.
Am I missing an area?
The answer would be...
Yes.
What is this?
Trash can.
Red door!
To get through here...
To get through here I think we need to go...
Inside, you guys.
To stay at home to make it to stream on time.
I don't... I didn't stream that early on Sunday.
You guys, I have... I put on my schedule.
I don't think I posted it to YouTube yet.
But...
Sunday I want to do a hand cam.
Where I get cookie dough.
And I try to shape it...
Into like Halloween things.
Like a bat...
Or a cat...
Or a pumpkin or whatever.
And...
Hope that when I cook it...
It turns out...
How...
How we put it into the oven.
The church is closed.
It's Sunday!
Oh, there is no response.
Alright, it didn't tell me that I cut all the grass though.
School ban performance in the park on Sunday.
Oh wait, I want to go!
The church is temporarily out of service.
I love cookies with Minto.
I don't really bake.
So who knows how these will turn out.
Cusa look at her.
Real.
It also didn't tell me that I cut all the hedges.
Because I didn't.
I see one.
Right here.
Alright guys.
Time to be brave.
Oh, there is something in there.
OK...
That's a painting.
No wonder it's out of service.
There is a dead guy in here!
Oh my god!
Wait, what is that?
Did you guys see that?
The snail is racing!
It wasn't a guy.
It was a snail.
Hello?
I got...oh it's a trumpet.
A magic trumpet.
Oh, the ghost calms down!
From the trumpet?
Is there anything else that I missed?
Wait, this is where I came from.
So let's go back around.
Hit the skeleton.
You think I can?
Sorry buddy.
Oh my god!
He is still okay.
Am I okay?
What's over here now?
Venture out of the garden!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
Oh, we did it!
Who is this for?
It is a war memorial.
I remember.
We can't leap?
Flip?
Oh, hello.
Okay, cool.
So we came from here.
Like this...what?
How?
What?
We went under...huh?
How did we...
What?
Okay.
Weird.
How did we...
Wait, there was a guy sitting here before.
Wasn't there not?
The bus is leaving on Monday.
What happened here?
What is happening in this city?
Guards!
Police!
Anybody?
What was that?
Did you guys see that?
There is someone in here.
Corn!
It's a scarecrow.
Somehow I don't think you needed to smack the skeleton with a hammer to get the bone.
Look.
I'm a ghost.
I don't really get how skeletons work.
We are at a gas station.
The gas station is closed today.
That's really inconvenient for...
Anybody who might need gas.
This scruffy character is asking for an egg ball.
What's an egg ball?
Wait, wasn't there...
Could be used to make something delicious.
There was the plate.
Maybe we need to make something there.
The garden key.
The music it creates sounds otherworldly.
Wasn't there Polaroids?
Oh, here we go.
Red door.
Gas station?
Oh, it's only for Saturday.
And midnight.
Wasn't there planks?
Here!
Planks!
What am I supposed to do with it?
That guy did not care for it.
Oh wait, high voltage.
That's the plank.
I know, I knew it.
Does it go to this?
I repaired the bridge.
I had a feeling.
Now we can just go in and out, baby.
Flip, flip, flip.
Sunday evening.
Trash.
Polaroid next to the bridge.
Yeah, yeah, I remember this one.
Thank you.
There's lots of trash.
Oh my god, are these all cigarettes?
These look like the marble cigarettes.
This place is disgusting.
I'm a gardener for the whole city now, apparently.
Got a coin though.
People are so rude.
Looks like America.
Tsk, tsk, tsk.
I feel like this is the kind of game where you have to look around every little corner, you know?
How do we...
Oh my gosh, how fast do we have to speedrun this game to...
...get to the gas station on Saturday?
Is it leaving?
But there's a door.
Maybe I can go.
Go, go, go.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I thought it was leaving.
On today's menu?
Snert.
Again.
I'm scared.
Why is it so dark in here?
And loud.
Hello.
This is a strange looking kid.
That's a rude comment.
This kid is looking very sad.
It is a hot bowl of snert.
Would you like a song?
Tough crowd.
Grab that coin.
I'm scared of seeing any mysterious figures in here.
Why is this place so...
I mean, this whole game is bizarre, but like...
This place in particular is very bizarre.
Interesting.
Terrible vibes, absolutely.
The bicycle somehow brings you...
Here.
What do you mean somehow brings me...
Oh, hello.
You cannot make out what they say.
They are playing some kind of game.
Oh, they will not let you take this special piece.
It literally says steal.
I just wanted to, you know...
Okay.
Guys, where are we?
I'm supposed to be a gardener.
Huh?
I'm spooked, I'm spooked.
Oh my god, am I in that SpongeBob episode?
This looks highly flammable.
Okay.
Can I go home?
Oh, again.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Don't care.
It's in my blood.
It's in my blood to cut the grass.
Okay, there is another...
What's this?
Welcome to Middlestum.
Oh my god, I see... Did you see him?
Did you see the scarecrow?
Oh, this place we gotta cut the grass.
I think I do need to cut the grass here.
I think I am sensing that I need to cut the grass here.
If I didn't need to cut the grass here...
Why is there a tall grass game?
You are giving me... You are allowing me to cut the grass.
I need to cut the grass.
I am sensing that I have to cut the grass here.
I'm just saying.
I think I have to cut the grass.
Otherwise it wouldn't be so tall.
Game, if I didn't need to cut the grass here you wouldn't give me the option to cut the grass.
Okay?
It's so tall.
Alright, let's go inside.
What's that?
Taking a nap?
Your home is a little flooded though.
Are you okay?
The Chihuahua!
Are you alright?
This person is... They are dead!
Oh god!
Oh my god!
Uh oh.
I can now...
We can now do the stuff!
Wait, what's this way though?
Hold on.
I know it's getting late.
Nothing like settling in with a nice bowl of snert watching a pair of YouTubers.
Oh, the dog looks curious.
Hello.
Give the bone!
The dog likes you!
Oh boy.
Fairy.
Okay.
We got a toy boat.
Toy boat.
What's that one tongue twister with the toy boat?
Something is awfully creaky here.
There's like... I need to water these too!
Toy boat.
Oh!
I'm too good at this game.
What are the letters for?
Mohel!
It will not budge.
Okay.
I have to go all the way around.
Wait, but I... Do you think I'll get... Do you think those mysterious whatever that tried to murder me before will try to murder me again?
If I'm not... I'm not cutting stuff.
I'm...
Molding stuff.
You could cut your way through here.
I think I'm...
A genius!
I'm in the garden!
Wait, we gotta do this before tomorrow!
We gotta get all this stuff before tomorrow!
Wait, I never found the watering can though.
What is this?
I think there's a severed hand outside my door.
Oh!
Wait.
But...
I'm the gardener.
This game is so mysterious.
This game is actually so mysterious.
Let's try putting the corn on the plate.
And we have to wait until midnight, remember?
To go to the church.
Nope, doesn't let me.
Okay.
Mohel's?
Can you mow my lawn?
For a steep price, I can.
There it goes, Pinto.
Uh-oh.
Guys?
Oh!
What the he...
Did you guys notice this before?
Oh, the mohels are gone!
It's a pretty looking pot.
Compass.
This gap is too deep to cross.
And there's something over there.
Okay.
Interesting.
We got all the mohels.
Yippee for us.
Somebody created a club in my house.
Uh
-oh.
It's jammed.
Oh...
I'm almost there.
I'm so close.
You do not have the key.
I think I'm in trouble.
It's that kid!
You perished in a strange hallway.
Huh?
Oh...
Is it you?
You must be the new gardener.
Do not be scared.
I do not mean to harm you.
I am trapped and you have to find me.
We cannot talk for much longer.
So I will keep this short.
There is an unwanted visitor.
Disguised as an ordinary worm.
Oh I thought it was the kid that just literally murdered me.
No way!
We never got to go to the church.
You have to find a way to get rid of it.
We have to conclude our conversation.
Is it because you took his toy?
I think maybe the toy boat I should have given to them.
I will now send you back.
What day is it?
Please be Saturday.
Progress?
1 out of 11.
Ares visited 14 out of 44?
Oh my gosh.
Polaroids collected 17 out of 42.
Polaroids solved 10 out of 42.
Wow!
It's Saturday!
Thank you Bus Driver.
Wait, is the grass short?
We are like totally blocked then.
Okay.
And then... Does it snap?
Okay, it does crack.
No!
This might be the worst game ever.
What's that sound?
Oh that, I think.
Wait.
Okay, wait, but the Polaroid is gone.
There was one in here, remember?
Endless gardening.
Yeah, I still have my Polaroids.
I do not have my items though.
Okay.
Interesting.
And then this.
Wait, I found a Polaroid?
Oh, there's things that are... Okay, the ones that are like full circles are ones that I've...
That I've completed this round.
Got it.
So...
Oh my gosh.
That guy is going to come back and see me again.
I knew it.
Okay.
The true horror of Groundhog's Day, loop of infinite lawn care.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
But like...
Okay, let's get all the stuff that I know that we need, right?
Oh, I guess I don't have to get that.
It's just a coin.
But you know, maybe I do need it.
Who knows?
Shut up, dog!
Why are you purple?
I don't know.
What?
Would you prefer me to be blue?
This was always here.
Interesting.
What is that over there?
Okay.
So I still have to cut this.
Oh, let's leave so we can get to the...
I think we have to have the little door handle pop up, right?
Let's leave so that we can get to the...
To the gas station.
What did Doki say?
Weak!
Okay, Doki.
Let's see you play this game, huh?
Let's see you play.
You wouldn't even be able to get down the hallway.
You don't even know my struggle.
You wouldn't even get there because you are too much of a baby.
You also wouldn't even know what to do because you can't read.
Doki bird.
Alright.
See, this area is so spooky, right?
Watch, this is a guy.
And this is a dead guy.
And I calmed that guy down.
Oh, the snail is like really far away.
He's racing.
I can play the game right now and beat the game while you are stuck.
I'm not even stuck!
I'm exploring!
Wait, wrong way.
I'm exploring.
Wait, stuck.
Stuck where?
Stuck who?
Look, I just opened the door.
Stuck my butt.
Oops, I accidentally got one of those flowers.
Whatever happened to Silent Hill 2?
What, is Doki stuck in Silent Hill 2?
Typical Doki.
What?
Is she only in there on Sundays?
Sundays is when I like to get stuck in the trunk.
This guy wanted an egg thingy.
Alright.
Oh, ok.
I cannot make out what they say.
Something is growling.
What is that?
Something is like...
You are not allowed to go there.
You cannot make out what they say.
Mata is taunting you about being in WME with Kojima.
First of all, you know...
I know she is doing her thing.
Try to follow the rules, you know, about like...
Oh!
Oh my god!
About like, you know...
Not...
Like, not bringing up other streamers unless I bring them up first or whatever.
But also...
She would not have known about that if I hadn't told her, so...
I'm the one who told her that he was in WME, so...
You know.
What is going on out here?
Oh my god, they do speak.
Are they gonna take over the...
Requires a key.
What is that?
Hammer time?
I think they are getting angry.
Oh my god, there is more!
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god!
Wait, they are never...
This is the worm, right?
Strange door...
Where is this?
Oh, I need my plank.
I forgot to go get the plank.
Strange door, as if nothing else here is strange.
You still want that egg ball or whatever the hell it was?
An egg ball.
Can't decide if people being on this island makes it spookier or less spooky.
Kind of odd you are not reporting the dead bodies.
You know, it's just...
It's just one of those things.
Oh, I forgot also to grab the bone.
Wait!
There is someone here.
You cannot make out what they say.
Why can't I understand you guys?
It's an empty fishbowl.
This one leads to...
This looks like where the gnomes live.
There is another dead guy!
I got the bone.
And I got a gnome idol!
I think they are going to come after me for real now.
But I killed all of them.
We are in the park!
The watering can!
This area could also use some gardening.
Praise the gnome, praise the gnome god.
Ok, so I have to clear the park.
I have to clear the church.
And I have to get our own garden.
We need a trowel.
Wait, but this is a grave.
It's a grave.
That's not a molehill, that's a grave.
What are the words spelling?
We had D...
Oh, this is where we came from, just kidding.
We had D... Oh my gosh!
I got a lighter.
E... What else was there?
Something in this area has changed?
The house?
What?
Huh?
I'm spooked.
What do you mean by that?
Let's try to find the watering can.
The van?
I don't think so.
The food truck is closed at the moment.
Ok.
What is this?
I wouldn't even know what was there to begin with.
Purified stone!
We know those people!
Woohoo!
I did it.
I don't know what the hell I'm doing.
This is a stunning piece of art.
Ok.
Anything is modern art nowadays, huh?
Even a turd emoji is modern art.
What about this one?
This is supposed to resemble art?
It's a literal pretzel!
What's wrong with that?
There it is!
Secret garden.
Guys, there is so much going on at all times in this game.
My brain cannot even keep up.
Empty mailbox.
It's a lot to remember.
Oh, here it is.
Candles.
Oh, we have a lighter.
But I think we need to...
light it...
when it gets to the twilight time.
Probably.
We still haven't gotten the trowel.
Which I don't remember where that was actually.
The dog is over here.
He looks curious.
It was near here, right?
Ok.
So let's go give this boat to the kids.
Wait, what was this one?
Dog happy bus game.
Dog so cute.
Ok, over here.
That's right!
Oh yeah, that's right!
It was in here!
Sorry guy.
Sorry.
Taking your trowel.
Obtain all garden...
Oh no, no, no, no!
There we go.
Obtain all gardening tools.
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
We actually almost just died.
There we go.
Oh my god.
What do I do with the...
Cannot make out what they say.
I'm cleaning up your garbage.
And I'm stealing your money.
Wasn't this a Polaroid?
But nothing happened.
Slick scooter.
Don't mind if I do.
Can I kill them?
Is that a snail?
Steal it?
I'm trying!
Oh, there is someone getting gas.
What do you have in your trunk?
Don't worry about it.
All these dead gnomes everywhere.
Requires a key.
Still so much I feel that we can do.
Still so much that I'm like what to do.
Okay.
All these dead gnomes everywhere.
Maybe I really didn't need to do that, huh?
Maybe I just should have let them live in peace, huh?
Maybe.
Alright, hold on.
Let's see.
Church door at midnight?
Compass.
I've never even seen this girl.
Oh, I forgot to go to the...
Let's go to the fairy.
Wait, did I see the fairy?
Oh yeah.
It's here.
I thought maybe it was a Sunday event only.
But no, it is very much here.
Let's give the children their toy, I guess.
And then...
There is also that couple there.
You solved the Polaroid.
I did?
Hello!
The toy manages to cheer up the kid.
This kid...
Oh.
We got the short idol.
Okay.
Stupid kid.
Can we now go through that hallway without dying because we don't...
But we don't have the key still though.
Let's see.
What do we have?
A strange small statue of a garden gnome.
We gotta go light the candles.
It might be too late, but let's try.
This game is cool.
It is pretty cool.
There is a lot to keep track of though.
It was in the park, right?
Yeah, it was in the park.
Happy dog.
There is always time to pet the dog.
Oh my gosh.
Run!
We are in the park.
Wait, the shop is open.
This might be our only chance.
Wait, is this the egg?
Is this the egg ball?
I got an egg ball!
Wow, that cost me so much money!
This guy better be worth it.
It's her!
Computer.
It cost 4F.
I need more money.
That guy took all my money.
Strange disk.
Office key.
Gold medal.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm here!
Okay.
Cool, we can go back to the gas station.
Oh my gosh, that dang egg ball took all my money.
That's the KFP house.
Uh oh, it's night time.
Wasn't there a Polaroid of this guy?
Oh no, this guy.
Trash.
What are those 3B...
Oh, I think they are the areas that they are in.
Right?
Like...
One is the garden.
Okay, that makes more sense.
Obtain kid's triangle.
You traded the egg ball for the triangle.
Okay, thanks!
Oh my gosh, a scarecrow.
She seems focused on something.
What?
What is she so focused on?
So creepy!
That wasn't the lady from the trunk, was it?
What was that?
We gotta wait for midnight.
Oh my god, the music is getting scarier.
Oh my god!
Turn it down just a little bit.
I haven't cut any of this stuff.
You think we are gonna be in trouble?
Fugoo, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Okay, hold on.
The triangle.
Cool.
Watering can.
Can you doot?
I can't tell if I was so scared that I...
Changed items or... Oh my gosh, it's getting really...
It's getting really kinda spooky out here.
Oh my god!
Leave me alone!
Just one more hour!
Let me in, please.
Please let me in.
Please let me in!
Twitch to trowel.
Well...
Might as well while we are waiting.
I thought...
I thought he was like attacking because I...
Was gardening past my bedtime, but...
Clearly he didn't care.
Okay, I'm afraid that midnight though is gonna get bad.
So I wanna stay in the area, you know?
I wanna stay so that if...
We get jump scared, you know?
You like that?
Oh my gosh, I mean rather if there is a chase scene...
If there is a chase scene, it's right there, you know?
Oh gosh.
Okay, 15 more minutes.
We are okay.
Midnight!
Hello?
Church key.
Store requires a key to unlock.
Store is shut tight.
There is no...
We got an old plank.
Okay.
Time to go to bed!
Okay, so we can go to sleep at midnight then.
Rather than going to sleep...
At like 9pm or whatever the hell we were doing before.
Is there something else in the grass?
Grass?
Oh my god!
Why do you leave your hand by the window?
You feel safe in here.
That's really good to know.
That I feel safe in here.
That's so...
That's so good to know.
Is there stuff out here then?
I don't know.
I feel safe in here?
After that?
Trying to see if other stuff happens.
Our vision is getting really wacky though.
You see that?
Okay, I'm just going to go to sleep.
I am going to go to sleep.
Good morning everybody!
Brand new day.
Everything is okay.
I'm ready to cut the grass and trim the hedges.
I'm ready to do my gardening duties.
Oh, the magpie.
Okay.
Cut some coosa.
And some mole hills.
I don't know how you are supposed to get everything done in time though.
Like, truly.
What was in here again?
Oh, the idols.
That's right.
Good morning, Minto.
Wait, can we put the plank here?
Yes!
Warning, this maze is very difficult to navigate.
Symbols!
Carry 20 items at once.
Interesting.
Weren't there kids in the park?
Like, didn't it say that they...
Were...
That there was like a... What's it called?
Some sort of...
Show in the park that the kids were doing or something.
Oh, there they are!
Yakuza fiance opening is so catchy.
Yeah, people were telling me about it.
Oh, I can give him the triangle.
And you...
This kid is missing their trumpet.
Give you the symbols.
I have a trumpet.
Okay, step aside kids.
I'm way better than you could ever be, kid.
You cannot make out what they say.
Of course I cannot.
Okay, let's check our stuff.
We need money for the compass.
We need to somehow get the church key.
The strange hallway, we need the key for that too.
And then trash?
Sunday evening.
So we do that tonight.
Yeah, we need to find the trumpet.
And then it said we need to cut grass in here too.
Holy moly, the life of a gardener.
I never expected it to be so tough.
Did I go in here?
Oh, there is another door.
Okay, just kidding.
Do you think the gardener or the owner of the house would be mad if I...
...didn't finish?
Oh, go through the maze?
Yeah, I guess we can attempt that, huh?
I'm afraid of dying.
Having to restart.
Do everything all over again.
Where was the maze again?
Oh, I know.
Over here.
Let's at least get the molehills, right?
Alright.
And the magpie, we heard that guy.
And we read that before.
Oh, the hedges.
Nice.
And then what else?
Oh my gosh!
Oh wow!
They really light up.
They come to life.
They are like born anew.
Each...
Find...
Find each ending and then restart the cleaning process.
Yeah, I know.
And I don't know what kind of endings there are either so far, so I'm just like...
Just kind of trying to do whatever.
Does this have anything in it?
No.
I think there was some more stuff over here to the water.
Are dead gnomes.
Everybody is dead.
Okay.
Oh, let's see if this lady is in here.
Oh, she is!
She is!
Is she alive, you think?
Okay.
She's taking a nap.
So true.
I guess we'll try the maze.
I also nap in my trunk, you know?
This is definitely the perfect place for nobody to bother you.
I guess the town gardener is doing his job well.
I'm not needed here.
Well, every time I walk through, I'll cut some more grass.
Alright guys, I'm gonna need your help.
Left or right?
This Outer Wilds is more chill.
This one feels like you're rushing against the clock, right?
Left?
Okay, I saw a lot of left.
This is a dead end.
I'm scared.
I'm stuck in a loop?
Hi!
Touching the symbol immobilizes you?
The walls start to move?
Am I dead?
No!
The new gardener.
Unwanted visitor.
It's a worm!
We haven't found a worm or anything like that.
Get mazed.
What if I don't kill the gnomes?
I wonder what will happen.
You know?
If I don't kill the gnomes, what will happen instead?
What if I cut this grass before...
Oh, nevermind.
Maybe we have to stand in the special areas.
Yeah, what do the letters mean?
What if I don't kill the gnomes?
I don't know, because I killed that one gnome to get the coin out of him.
Are they going to be angry?
Are they going to be like...
Yo man, we know you killed that gnome.
We're coming for you in your sleep.
Are they going to have a gnome takeover?
It's so gnome over.
Letters say skill issue.
I followed your advice.
You guys said...
Go to the left, Minto.
And then everything else was either a dead end or...
You know?
Everything else was one way.
Go to the left, Minto.
That's the correct way.
That's the correct way, Minto.
You gotta go to the left.
I don't want to be gnomed.
And there's going to be guy right...
Now!
I'm not afraid anymore, guys.
I've grown stronger.
Braver.
Braver than ever before.
Recent streams are all maid duties?
I guess kind of, huh?
Oh, I forgot to get the hammer.
That guy is talking.
He's saying a lot of words over here.
I don't know.
I guess I'm just drawn to the maid...
It's like, you know...
The maid...
Some...
My destiny, you know?
My maidly instincts.
What if I use the plank...
To fix...
To not fix this.
Till later.
And we went back into the maze.
Let's try that.
Let's get the plank to not fix the maze just yet.
Or fix the bridge and go through the maze instead.
Wait.
How do I do... Oh yeah.
We gotta get the...
We gotta get the door handle.
This guy is here!
La la la.
It's an important maid duty of escaping a Soviet base, riding a sidecar on a motorcycle and shooting a machine gun.
I mean...
I might only be speaking for myself here, but...
Do you think the signs say gnome?
Oh, there it is.
Like, we have an O.
We have an M.
Give me an O!
Give me an M!
Give me a...
What else?
What else was... A D!
Mindo doesn't have a D in it.
Don't lie.
Is it this one?
Where the hell is the exit?
Oh, here we go.
Money.
Money, money, money.
Alright, let's get this plank and then let's go back to...
Oh, here.
Go back.
When did the gnomes show up?
I can buy a lighter!
I mean, I just found one before.
What?
They are scamming people!
You can find one in the park!
And instead you have the option to buy one?
No!
To go back though, I'm gonna have to go back through the church.
It's a little bit inconvenient, but...
Whatever.
I can just find one on the ground and instead you are charging people?
Absolute scam.
Scam, scam, scam.
Ok, it worked.
Alright guys.
We are gonna go to the right.
Which one do we go through?
One or two?
Two?
I saw two first.
Oh.
Wait.
Huh?
Who?
Oh, I forgot to get the hammer.
Wait, there is only one...
There is only one way to...
Gosh.
Wait a second.
Huh?
No!
What are you doing up there?
Why are you looking at me like that?
Ok, I'm not gonna touch it obviously.
No!
Ok, I guess let's restart our day.
Oh my gosh, how lame.
No!
At least it was early after all.
Oh!
That's so cute, his move.
Yeah, I succumb to the maze.
Gosh.
Yeah, I think I'll need an item or something, something.
Ok, well if we can't do the maze...
The compass!
Oh my gosh, yes, probably.
And if I don't buy...
If I don't buy the... What's it called?
The egg ball.
We should be able to buy the compass instead.
Can you jump down the well?
I can try.
Before it was just like...
I see no end in sight for this well.
How are you supposed to do everything in this game?
I guess if you stay up until midnight...
You're a real rebel.
You can get it all done in time, I guess.
There's the magpie.
There's the gnome.
My nemesis.
Ok, perfect.
Give me one second guys.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on, am I forgetting something?
Am I forgetting something?
Sorry guys, I just got jammed and I'm like...
Wait, there was no plan for this.
Oh my gosh, ok.
Sorry.
Everything's good.
Everything's fine.
Everything's all good.
No worries.
I just saw I had so many DMs all of a sudden.
I was like, what's going on?
What did I miss?
But it was all nothing.
Well, it's something, but it's all good.
Give me hammer.
And... jump scare.
Ok.
Give me scissors.
Give me power.
Give me magpie.
Whatever Minto tells him not to cry.
I can't make out what she's saying.
What are you talking about?
Wait, did I fix this?
Oh no, we haven't left.
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting all my...
My ReZero reruns...
Confused.
Wait, the guy's not here.
Interesting.
Is he only here at a certain time?
But it's like, he's like here really early then.
Oh wait, we gotta cut the grass so we can get the doorknob.
Doorknob, doorknob.
I gotta get the trowel.
Wasn't there...
Oh, it was in the park.
Not here.
It was like the little grave mole hill.
Doorknob, doorknob.
Doorknob, where are you?
Doorknob, come to me.
Oh, I think I just cut a thing.
Oh, what if I cut all these?
Oh.
Mister?
I never got the...
I
never got the trumpet.
The doot-doot.
Oh my gosh, please no.
Oh my god.
Well, we discovered another ending, I guess.
Quick death.
Okay.
I didn't think I would die so suddenly.
Gosh.
Well, now we know they are sacred flowers.
Do not grub...
the sacred flowers.
Stand in the magical light, maybe.
It's a good thing.
Who knows?
I have no idea what's good and what's bad anymore in this game.
I have no idea.
Yeah, we could try it again once we have the doot-doot.
Try and calm them down.
Like I said, all my runs are getting...
Like...
They are all getting...
Mixed up together.
It's okay though.
All I did was do this stuff, so...
Honestly...
Didn't miss so much.
I just made it to the garden.
And we gotta get more money.
Let's try and get... Let's aim for the compass this time.
Let's aim for the compass.
No, I think the compass is for the maze.
I have a feeling.
I have a feeling it's for the maze.
Right?
Otherwise, there is nothing else.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I have a Java update.
lol Did I get all the... Oh, here is some more hedges.
There we go.
We trimmed the hedges.
Hi, windows.
Windows jump scare.
Oh, there is all this to water too.
Oh my gosh, this game is like...
Actually so much...
That I didn't expect.
So much more like...
In depth than I imagined it to be.
But it is really satisfying.
I kinda wish there was just a mode where you can cut the grass.
Wish there was a mode where I just cut the grass and go on my merry way.
You thought it was kusoge?
kusoge?
No, I remember when I was watching the other person play, I was like...
This seems kind of interesting and mysterious.
You know me.
I love a good mystery.
There it is.
I love me a good mystery.
It's a kusoge.
I'm alive.
Hello snail.
Why was the snail before so close to the finish line?
And now every time I see him...
He is not close at all.
It's very mysterious.
Because I took forever?
Was it because it was close to Sunday?
You can't say I took forever.
I was exploring.
I was looking at everything.
I was investigating.
Yeah, sure, I was taking forever.
Can you cut the corn, I wonder?
Oh, that's right.
There is the corn.
By the scarecrow.
I'm scared.
Where is the scarecrow?
Oh, over here.
Corn.
Thank you, scarecrow.
It gets really dark in there, so it spooks me a little bit.
By a little bit, I mean like a lot a bit.
Guys, I can't remember where we all got money from.
I think we should rob this place.
Lady, give me all that you got.
Vandalism.
That's me in the future.
What, the grandma?
I think there is one in here.
Alright, so we have how much?
We have five.
Wait, that's all we need.
So, let's see.
The dog is over here.
I don't have a bone for him though.
We need the trowel in here.
I know how it works.
Money.
There is a coin.
Fortnite skin.
This person is dead.
Good thing too.
They don't notice me robbing them.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm gonna drown.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
That was bad.
That was really bad.
Hey puppy.
The dog looks angry.
There is a guy fishing over there.
Wait, I need to get some bone.
I need to get a bone.
I'm currently boneless.
Which, in another story, might be a good thing.
Alright, let's go get the bone.
I don't remember where the second bone was that I could have gotten.
I don't remember, so I'm just gonna go back in here and grab it.
Oh.
So eager to leave.
Thank you.
This way.
Cut some more grass every time I go through.
Oh, grab some more trash every time I go through.
Empty plate.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Come here dog.
I got you a bone.
Oh my god, I see that guy fishing.
I see him over there.
Good boy.
Grab that.
Oh my gosh, I'm running around at the speed of sound.
Trying to find what's going on in this town.
What?
Why can't I understand anybody?
Oh no, we can't go through here.
I didn't buy the lighter.
Alrighty.
What else was there?
Find the lighter in the park.
Yeah, but I gotta get to the park.
I found the lighter!
No way!
There's no gnomes this time.
Interesting.
Is it because I didn't kill the initial gnome?
Should I kill the initial gnome?
When you pick up a lighter, it makes you heavier.
Wait, what do you mean?
Is there weight in this game?
I don't feel slower.
It makes me lie!
Shut up.
Wait, how do I open this door, you guys?
How do I open it?
Not like that.
Anything in here?
No?
Dig up the grave.
Oh yeah, that's right!
Where was it?
A little grave.
I'm gonna dig it up.
There better not be a hand in there.
Oh, it's a dead goldfish.
Maybe the fisherman wants it for bait!
Let's try it.
Someone's dead little fish.
He's gone.
Dang it.
Okay.
How do I open the mysterious door?
Things are already different.
Something in the area has changed.
Oh, the door!
That must be it.
Yes!
We have to wait until night time though.
Okay.
What happens if you just garden like you're supposed to?
I...
I don't know.
From the beginning was just like...
You have to leave to get all the items like...
Like the travel and the...
And the watering can.
So you can't just stay in there the whole time.
You have to leave.
And then you start getting curious.
You know?
When you're curious...
You start investigating.
When you investigate, that's when you discover...
Three dead bodies...
In this town that nobody has noticed.
Or four, I guess, technically.
And then you say, hmm...
I think something is amiss here.
You know?
Purple mint is cute.
Hope everyone has a good day.
You too!
Thanks, Trashboat.
You have to leave.
Ah!
I found it.
Found the silly grass.
I know we have to... Well, I guess...
There was one thing that was a Sunday night thing, right?
Oh, and there's also these people!
Oh my gosh.
We gotta get the compass.
But then she also had an office key, which makes me think that we would go to the office.
Church door at midnight.
We gotta find the church key somehow.
The bone.
Fairy.
Trash, we haven't done yet.
Maze, we haven't... Oh, I guess these are deaths.
Yeah, we've done these deaths.
The sacred flowers, okay.
Let's just hang around here until we can light the candles, I guess.
We'll just do our duty.
Our lonely duty.
Even though this is...
For some reason we feel motivated to...
To garden in some areas and not in others.
I don't quite understand it.
Maybe because I'm not a gardener.
I don't have that sense, you know?
I don't have that gardening sense.
Maybe around now?
Yes, okay.
Hello, I would like to buy this compass.
I have 6F and I need 4.
Thank you!
Guys, I just remembered.
Where did I get that other plank from?
The silly grass!
Okay.
Inside the church.
That's right!
So we do have to go to the church.
At midnight.
Oh my gosh.
Church door opens at midnight.
Silly grass!
I'm purifying all the grass.
I'm not quite sure what I'm doing.
I guess while we wait, let's garden!
Let's garden while we wait!
Do do do do do...
Are there any... Can I water these?
No.
Viewers in chat are discussing a bad joke told by Minto.
What did I say?
What are you talking about?
What bad joke?
There's only winners here.
Coin?
Where coin?
Werewolf, where coin?
You dug it up and left it.
What?
I did?
Over here?
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
I didn't even notice.
I didn't even know that could happen.
I'm blind.
Sorry!
Sorry, I'm a humble... I'm a humble gardener, please.
Please.
Please, give me mercy.
Mercy, mercy.
Oh, they're gonna start jump scaring me soon.
They're gonna start jump scaring me soon.
How humble are we talking?
Mom, breasts are small and humble.
Shakira levels of humble.
Something mountains.
They're not giant mountains.
60% I guess a lot of it is over here.
This other side.
I was literally about to... I was literally about to...
I was literally about to... I was about to say...
I was about to say I'm surprised we haven't been jump scared yet.
Oh my God.
I couldn't even speak right.
It got me good.
Cannot see the bottom.
It won't let me in there.
Oh, we have to find the... Wait, where was the paddle?
I feel like I recognize this, but...
I feel like I recognize these sticks.
Music is so chill for what is definitely not a chill area.
Or chill time of the day.
No jump scare, please.
I'm doing my job.
I'm a humble gardener.
When will it say that we've cut all the grass?
God.
Oh my goodness.
It gets me every time.
Time.
Time to go to bed.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Not yet, not yet, not yet.
Good, good, good, good.
Knock, knock.
Okay.
Okay, shut tight.
Do you think I can make it through the maze?
Oh my God, I hear him talking, the gnome.
You enter the maze with a confident feeling.
But it's really dark in here.
I'm leaving.
It's really dark.
I think we should come back.
Strange happenings are about to happen.
Oh, like the radio on and stuff.
What?
Oh my God, you again.
With your stupid ass hand.
Stop leaving me presents.
See?
Oh, this is what I recognized the sticks from.
But there is no paddle.
Okay.
Alright.
Have confidence.
This way.
Wait, this is an actual maze now.
Wait.
Hold on.
I was just messing around for a second.
It's an actual maze now.
Okay, hold on.
It's a delicate looking fountain.
It seems to be unaware of your presence.
He looks like he's a soldier.
Like he looks like he's...
Can you use the compass?
I don't think so.
Wait.
I think it just allowed us to...
Prevents you from getting lost.
I think it just allows us to go through the... to actually do the maze.
Graveyards are actually the least haunted place.
As very rarely if anybody dies in a graveyard.
Oh, we have a ghost expert over here.
What do you mean prevents you from getting lost?
Wait, this is where I came from.
It did prevent me from getting lost.
Okay, hold on.
Can we do anything to the fountain?
Maybe I should have smashed it.
Checking out if there is anything else in here though.
Prevents you from getting lost.
Those words keep ringing in my head.
Delicate.
If it's delicate.
Not smashable.
Cuttable?
No.
Dickable?
Nothing.
I can't even like throw a coin in there.
Maybe we are missing another part of the maze puzzle.
That's a little frustrating.
How much money do I have?
Doesn't say.
Oh my gosh, I never...
I never went and got the other plank.
How silly of me.
Here, let's do some gardening while we are here.
Let's get some of these mole hills.
Don't make a mountain out of a mole hill.
Oh, there is trash in here.
Trash.
Oh, and we can also...
Water, water, water, water, water.
Thanks for the super chat.
What is this game?
It's actually pretty intriguing I'd say.
I think it really...
It's like...
Feels fast paced enough to kind of like keep your energy...
Or your attention, you know?
But it's also mysterious enough that I...
Can't stop.
I didn't get all the trash, I don't think.
I don't know where all the trash is at.
Mysterious flower.
Did I get all of them?
Oh wait, no.
Oh, I watered all the flowers.
Oh my gosh, we are at 96% you guys.
Maybe it is possible.
Maybe.
97% Wait, something was...
It's a normal garden gnome.
He was not there before.
I saw him move.
I saw him move in my peripheral.
Is it this guy?
He moved!
Oh my god, he moved.
Do you think he is after me?
I wish this was also like... What is it called?
Oh my gosh, I cleared all the trash.
I didn't even notice that.
I wish this was a little bit like...
Power wash simulator where I could click and find what areas I've missed.
I reached 100% in the garden.
Wait, a mysterious pass?
Oh my gosh, what is this?
Can I fit through here?
Skinny legend?
The perfect place for a picnic.
Okay.
Normal garden gnome.
I'm skinny legend, everybody.
When I say I'm dieting, this is what I mean.
What am I doing?
Oh, this stays open.
It requires a key and a shut tight.
We still haven't gotten the paddle.
I still don't know where that is.
What is this?
Are there any flowers to water in here?
Doesn't seem like it.
I'm trying to like 100% this area.
Is that trash?
No.
I'm trying 100% this area so I can...
I'm scared of cutting these on accident.
Because if a portal appears every time you 100% an area...
And it says we need a picnic, maybe we gather the supplies for a picnic in the other areas.
Perhaps is my hypothesis.
The polaroid for the paddle said 830.
Oh, 830.
830.
PM?
AM?
Did I miss it?
Water these?
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
I missed it.
I didn't see these.
Very good, very good.
Can I water here?
No.
Can I jump in there?
Who cares if I can't see the bottom.
I think we did it.
100%!
I didn't get an achievement this time though.
Secret passage?
Secret passageway.
Secret passageway!
Ignore the big pieces of grass.
Oh, there it is!
What?
Steel!
I got the cute blanket.
Now run before somebody kills me.
We got the blanket.
A blanket for a picnic!
Let's go try and 100% the park now.
I suppose.
Is our... How much do I have of here?
Oh, we are at 63.
This is possibly doable.
Sorry children, I don't care about your instruments and your happiness.
I don't care about you and your little stupid recital.
You sound like Dookie anyway.
I'm a better trumpet player than that girl will ever be.
Is there anything here?
Money!
I'm a gardener, but I was born for the stage.
I'm a gardener, but I always had a passion for trumpet.
I'm a gardener, but my parents forced me into the family biz.
I always wanted to be a trumpet player.
What my parents said.
You dummy.
You were born into this family.
Oh my gosh, that reminds me actually.
I recently watched Coco for the first time.
The movie.
Remember me.
I'm a something, something, something.
I kind of had an issue with the movie.
I'm not gonna lie.
I liked it, obviously.
It was very cute.
I liked it.
But I kind of...
And maybe this is just my...
This is obviously not everybody's experience in life or afterlife.
But I kind of...
Felt like...
A little weird about how they...
So...
Much they were like...
Oh, you know.
Your family.
Your family is everything.
Your family, family.
But like, whatever, you know.
I feel like it would be really sad if someone...
Didn't have a good family.
And...
Like, watch that.
It was just like...
How am I supposed to feel?
So when I die, I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna disappear because, you know.
I don't have a family to put on my little photo or whatever.
I just felt kind of like...
They really went fast and furious.
I don't know.
That was my only thing about it.
Because, you know.
Um...
Yeah.
Okay.
What else?
Is there any more flowers to water?
More grasses to cut.
But I really liked it, other than that.
That was like, like I said, my only...
It's not even like a big problem.
It's just something that I was just like...
Oh, huh.
Okay.
Not water these.
We're at 94%.
What are we missing?
Have you guys seen anything we need to water?
Metal Gear Solid teaches us that family doesn't have to be genetically related.
Family can be your brother's arm attached to it that loves your dad.
So true!
I missed a molehill?
I did?
Little molehill.
Where?
Where is the molehill?
I did?
Something fell out!
Oh my god, I just robbed the tree.
Oh, there, there, there, thank you.
But we're only at 95%.
And it's getting late.
Uh-oh, guys.
What else am I missing in here?
These guys.
You cannot make out what they say.
Can I take your stuff?
I got a pizza box.
Can I take your car?
Slick scooter.
Okay.
Water everything.
All I did was water these.
And those flowers over there.
What am I missing in here?
I can't tell.
I've gotten like most of the grass, I feel.
Usually it's very easy to tell if you need to water it.
The ladder.
What, you think I have to go upstairs?
No.
I don't think I need to go back there.
I haven't checked in a while.
Any update with the plush?
They are in production.
Sorry I can't say much more than that.
Oh, in here, in here.
Oh my gosh.
100% progress in all areas.
It says Master Gardener.
A sandwich.
What are these?
A bunch of bread.
They sell normal bread and long bread.
Hello, yes?
I would like one long bread.
It all looks quite fresh.
Nobody cares that I stole, right?
Will the plush have a nifty light stick hole at the bottom?
No.
But, you could make your own hole.
I don't recommend it.
If you would like to have a hole...
Wait, where is the hole here?
Oh, over here.
If you would like...
You should buy multiple.
Okay, lay down the blanket.
I put the sandwich on the blanket.
And we picnic!
Oh my gosh.
I did so much.
Is there a point to tending the garden?
Did you die?
What if I choked on the sandwich?
It was poisoned.
Because I stole it.
She is a thief.
I didn't know there was a plush.
There will be one.
I won't shut up about it.
If you follow me on Twitter, you've seen the plush.
I didn't die though, because I didn't see that guy.
20?
There is still...
There is still 20 more areas we haven't been to.
What?
Wait, we've almost met...
It says characters met 17 out of 18.
We've almost met every character.
Interesting.
Okay.
I feel like there is...
Probably need to get that ore at 830.
Probably.
Will you ever do additional production runs if there is more demand?
Or do we just have to wait and see what the future holds?
At the moment...
I don't have any other plans.
But I would never say never.
Wait, why is he here?
Instead of all the way over here.
He is permanently moved.
Our little gnome.
Interesting.
See, we have so much.
We have the plate.
There is still so much to...
To investigate.
There is the gnomes.
All the gnomes.
He is slowly encroaching on the starting zone.
I don't like his whispers.
Oh, let's go.
Sorry.
I'm not even going to bother...
Being a gardener anymore.
Because there is no point in gardening.
I've learned.
3, 2, 1, jump scare!
Gardening gives you money though?
Wait, it does?
I'm gardening?
Self-fulfillment?
Yeah, I felt really good getting 100% in all 3 areas.
I did!
I felt really good about myself.
I'm not going to lie, I was just like, yeah!
I did it!
I was like, woohoo!
I'm really good at this.
I'm really good at this job.
Wait, how does it give you money?
You just need the molehills for the easy money.
When does this open up?
What do you mean?
Why are you acting like you are a professional at this game?
Okay.
We still have the...
The office key?
Okay.
I just realized...
Guys, I think I'm going to restart.
Wait, where do we get the ore tomorrow?
Hold on.
Is it 8.30 PM or AM?
No, it's got to be AM.
It's 8.30 AM that you get the ore.
But where is the paddle?
Yeah, it's a 24 hour clock.
But where is this?
Is it where I think it is?
Is it this little... And this guy here too.
So mysterious.
There's like certain people that just show up and disappear at the most random times.
It's not here, I don't think.
No.
Backside of the shack?
Oh, it will be here.
Okay.
Guys... Oh, money.
8.30 AM.
Okay, tomorrow morning.
I should have gotten it.
Ah, should I restart?
Restart!
It's only 10.30, should I restart?
What time do we get here?
At 9 or do we get here at 8?
Let's continue seeing what other things we can solve before we...
Like the silly grass.
Let's see what other things we can solve before we... We can still get tomorrow.
Just have to remember.
First thing in the morning.
Behind the shack.
Alright, door handle!
Perfect.
Jump scare in 3, 2, 1!
The snail!
Oh, calm down.
Chill out.
Okay, nevermind.
Thank you.
Party grass better have some good lore.
I know!
That's what I'm saying.
And then there is this lady in here?
You know what?
I am gonna kill the gnome.
I'm gonna kill the gnome and see what happens.
Don't kill the gnome.
Why not?
What has he done for me ever?
Okay, I have 3 F.
Steal their idol.
And then there is the couple playing mahjong or whatever.
Money?
I still always wanna pick up the garbage though.
Alright.
There is also the corn?
Yes, there is the corn.
I tried putting it on the plate and it didn't work.
So I wonder...
What the corn is for?
Like you would think...
It's for...
Okay, bye.
You would think it's for...
Eating?
Don't show it.
For the maze?
You are killing me.
I'm already dead.
That's right.
What if I water these?
Inspect.
Oh, that's an empty mailbox.
Let's go give the boat to the...
The fairy to the...
The boat toy to the fairy kids.
I feel like there is still so much that we have not...
Done.
There is just...
An insane amount.
If I try to steal the gnomes' idols when they are alive...
Will they be upset by that?
There you go.
I'm so angry!
Wasn't there money in here?
I'm robbing.
Why does it sound like I'm not wearing shoes?
He looks so mad.
Does that one molehill still have a lighter?
Let's go check.
Let's go see if it does or not.
I wonder if it...
Has a lighter.
Or if it...
I wonder if the lighter will be in the park if you don't get it from there.
And you don't buy it.
Shofi?
I don't have any.
This guy.
Oh yeah, that's right.
Do you want the dead goldfish?
I can get it for you.
He's still there.
Don't go anywhere mister.
I'm watching you.
Fishbowl?
There was the fishbowl!
That's right.
Wait, how did we get into there?
How did we get into where the fishbowl was?
Hold on, he's still here.
I can ask him.
Hey mister!
Mister!
The gnomes!
Wait, do I actually...
Wait, the gnome cave.
This game is so much.
Give me money!
No tip?
It's dark in here.
You look out over a big sea.
Yeah, I remember the gnome idol.
I don't remember how to get to the gnome idol.
You only get paid for completing tasks in the garden itself.
Gotcha!
Thank you.
For letting me know.
Yeah.
And then this.
Looks like we plant something in there.
Everything is just so confusing in this game.
Here, let's water the plants first.
This one is pretty easy.
This is an easy one.
We can do it quickly.
We'll do this one.
I'm not going to cut all the grass for the money.
But we can...
We can water all the plants.
Collect all the trash.
And cut the hedges.
And the moles.
That should give us a good amount of money.
Oh, here too.
Excuse me!
Why are you being so difficult?
Oh!
Okay.
Yeah, the grass is just like...
A ton.
But we want to get the stuff from the other...
From the other girl.
I forgot these.
What?
What did I miss?
Do you think maybe the fish goes on here?
No.
Oh, trash.
Did I miss one in here?
No.
Untrimmed hedge.
Yeah.
I know I didn't get all the hedges.
But I was looking for all the plants.
Wait, so how much...
Oh, you get two!
Wow!
Oh, two whole...
F...
Coins.
Let's go.
Clear all the trash.
That's two more!
What did I miss for the...
For the flowers though.
Foins.
Yeah, we got two more foins.
Still haven't seen this guy with his hand.
I 100%ed this area, so I'm like...
I should know where all of it is.
Got rid of all the molehills.
Plus two foins.
Two whole francs.
If you guys see a plant that I missed...
Holler.
Just say, hey.
Is
it by the shed?
We are.
The tiniest little flower ever.
So what we need is...
It's in the park.
Is the door to the girl...
It's the...
Ok, how do we first unlock it?
There is some way to unlock it.
And we gotta be speedy, because...
Oh my gosh.
We gotta be like hella speedy.
Because...
What was it again?
There we go!
There we go.
You don't want the lighting.
Ripped you out of it.
Why did you die?
What happened?
Ok, we have 14.
We can buy a gold medal.
We can buy the strange disc.
We can buy the office key.
Which I have not even seen the office.
I wonder if the strange disc...
Ok, maybe the...
Ok, the compass is...
We know the compass is for the maze.
The gold medal, I wonder if it's for like...
Oh my god, my contact.
I wonder if it's for the...
Either the well?
Or...
I think it's either for the well.
Or for...
That couple playing the game.
Garden gnome.
Medal for the snail?
Oh the office is probably in the gas station.
You're right.
Oh we would have to go like right now.
Ok, let's check it out.
Let's go.
How much more do I have?
12?
Red door to the church.
Gas station.
Omnium Prime.
Thanks for joining membership.
Thank you.
Strange door.
Yeah, computer.
Buy all the things.
See, because it's purified stone.
I'm wondering if it's the medal or the disc.
For them, you know.
There was that thing that they wouldn't let me steal.
And we gotta get the church key somehow too.
Is that the fairy?
Trash.
Sunday evening.
Strange hallway.
We didn't have a key for that door.
I don't think we will have a key for that door.
Unless...
These are all ways...
These are all our funny ways to die.
Including picnic.
Probably have to destroy the gnome since it's on a Polaroid.
Probably.
Dumb ways to die.
I guess we'll grab the...
There was that bale of hay near them that said it was flammable.
You're right!
Okay, I'm gonna grab the medal.
Because it's expensive.
And let's leave quickly to the gas station.
And then from the gas station, we can go check on that couple.
Wait, if it's the computer on the office, you might need the disc.
Wait, you might be right.
Ah!
Shout!
No!
Time to kill a gnome.
For money.
I'm a hired hitman now.
Sorry.
Am I really sorry?
I don't know.
There's also the corn.
Wait, that guy is not going down anymore.
He's just chilling up there.
Oh my gosh.
So scary.
I think they are coming after me.
I think we do need the disc.
We got an apple.
Apple on the plate!
I won't let you destroy me.
I won't let you kill me.
Look at all these gnomes, right?
Crazy.
Could use some help.
Could use some help with these guys.
It's fine though.
Whatever.
It's fine.
I guess I don't need it.
Alright, let's do the...
Apple on the plate.
Did it say...
Like a...
Time or anything?
Nope.
It gave us...
Some kind of worm?
I'm gonna go feed it to the bird.
Do you want this worm?
Feed a bird.
Was the... Something mysterious happened behind me?
Obtained a strange key.
This key feels very important.
OK
Alright.
Rip the worm.
No guys, remember!
Remember the worm!
Remember, when we kept dying...
The guy said there's a worm.
There's an evil worm that is...
That is here.
That we are trying to get rid of.
Let's see if we can...
Damn.
So this gold coin is useless I think.
This gold medal.
For real winners only.
Wait, maybe I do give it to the snail.
Snail!
Oh god, you scared me.
Oh, he's almost there!
Is it for the strange hallway where the kid got you?
Let's try the other doors in the house first.
Or like, let's try everything that's locked currently.
Like you, it's closed.
Um...
Let's wait until midnight...
To go in there.
Oh gosh, we're gonna start getting jump scared soon guys.
I'm scared!
I'm nervous.
Let's try the house.
Off limits, locked.
What was this door?
Oh, this is the gnome!
That's right.
I placed the dead goldfish in the fishbowl.
Gnome idol.
Wait, what's this?
We got...
Oh my god.
You guys, we're solving everything right now.
We are solving everything right now.
Silly grass?
Silly grass!
Will I have enough money to buy the instruments though?
We're like getting everything.
We're doing so well.
How's the dog doing?
Dog is good.
Hi baby!
How much money do I have?
Oh my gosh!
I met every... I talked to every character.
I just never... I just didn't talk to her before.
Oh, I have four.
Okay.
Silly grass.
I'm baby.
Are you?
Exactly enough for the compass at least.
Or the disc.
Whichever we get...
First, I suppose.
I forgot to go to the couple.
I wonder...
If we can do that.
Gonna start getting jump scared soon.
Oh wait, we gotta...
Actually, let's just go back.
I know I ran all the way over here.
But the church door is gonna open soon.
And I don't wanna miss that.
I don't wanna miss the church door.
All these dead, dead gnomes.
I see!
Thanks for two months!
Hey, I'm just a gardener.
I'm just a gardener.
Don't jump scare me, okay?
I'm just doing my job.
Don't jump scare me, please.
Okay, let me in!
Require... Okay, so it's not that key.
Okay.
And it's not that key.
Now we know.
Oh, the snail, the metal?
Do you think he's done?
Can I give it to him?
He didn't finish the race!
Oh my gosh, it's so dark.
So scary.
Don't jump scare me in here, please.
Yeah, he's still racing.
We can't just give him a medal.
We don't know if he's a winner.
Rare unedited perfectly cut screen.
Wrong way.
Here we go.
Oh, wrong way.
Hmm.
Let's see if that passageway has opened up in our bedroom.
Let's see.
There was a party in my shack.
I don't feel safe in here at all!
Stop giving me your hand!
Also guys, remind me, as soon as we wake up...
OK.
As soon as we wake up...
Wait, but where is the door?
Maybe it's on Sunday?
OK.
That kid is haunting me!
Go, go, go!
Get the door!
Got it!
That kid is haunting me!
A reminder battle.
Thank you!
Did I block his face?
I don't know.
He showed up like in the bottom right corner.
Alright, let's go see what this leads to.
That's it?
They probably expect you to get it sooner.
Maybe.
I wonder why this one doesn't...
Wait, do I go give him his hand back?
Wait, but I can't get in there.
I wonder if I'm supposed to give him his hand?
I wonder if I'm supposed to...
Like, after I see him in the window...
Can I... or can you?
I don't know.
Because there is no, like, checkmark next to it.
Yeah, we'll go check on the snail.
Don't you worry guys.
I'm afraid of drowning.
Sounds like my cat.
Let's back down.
Bring the severed hand to where it belongs.
You're welcome.
That was so easy.
Let's go check on our snail.
Wait, I'll go this way.
And look!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Let's see if the key goes to... I'm almost positive the key is to the door that happens at the end of the hallway.
But it doesn't hurt to try other doors as well.
Just in case.
Is it fine though if I don't do anything in the gardens?
Is it okay though?
I don't know.
He's almost there.
Maybe I need to do more stuff.
Maybe his progress is reflective of my progress.
Maybe I... Let's see.
Oh wait.
Okay, hold on.
We get the triangle...
From the...
From the guy...
In the park.
By the gas station I mean.
Sorry.
We get...
Yeah, we need the egg ball.
It's not open.
It might open later.
But I don't remember where we get the other instrument.
I don't quite remember that.
Snip, snip, snip.
Maybe the more I snip, the more progress the snail will have.
And let's do this too.
The maze area.
Oh, the symbols.
That's right.
Thank you.
Okay, yeah.
Let's go back and do that.
Yes, there is the entrance to the maze.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's right.
We get more money by completing stuff in an area.
So let's just do the mole hills here.
Oh, and more money baby!
Let's do the mole hills here.
We can ignore all the grass.
Oh my gosh guys, we are gaming, we are gaming, we are gaming!
We are so gaming right now.
Snipe, snipe, snipe.
I need more mole hills.
Mole hill, mole hill, mole hill, mole hill...
Huh?
Moheo, moheo, moheo, moheo, moheo, moheo.
Where did I...
Where did I miss it?
This is the grun, guys.
Not the grun.
The thing my friends and I, we really love is the...
Is the picture of like...
Have you guys ever seen the picture of the dog that's like dyed green?
And they're like, it's the grunch.
Or whatever.
We laugh about him every year.
Maybe I don't get money for here.
The gunch.
Yeah, it's the gunch.
I found nothing.
There are holes in the tree.
Sometimes.
We're gonna make it.
Do I not make money for these areas?
Did I miss something?
I don't think I missed anything.
It's a pretty looking vase.
I think they only pay you at the main garden for work.
Dang.
Oh well.
We got an extra coin, so we can afford the...
Oh.
Oh, please.
We can afford...
I think we can afford the CD, the disc.
Oh, let's go see that couple.
And set their stuff on fire.
Let's go set their things on fire.
And let's go save this lady.
You okay?
Are you still alive?
I don't know.
You bought the disc, didn't you?
No, I bought the gold medal.
I got the gold medal.
Oh, the snail.
Sorry.
Oh my gosh, my brain is everywhere with this game.
I'm like, let's go do this.
Oh, wait, I forgot about this.
Let's go do this.
My brain with this game is so crazy.
But the egg also cost $5.
You're right.
How do we get more money in this game?
He's so close!
I think it's my progress, guys.
I think I gotta do more.
Hmm, okay.
ADHD simulator.
There's just so much.
Oh, the corn.
I'm gonna grab as much as I can...
and just throw something against the wall...
and see what works, you know?
The sky is still...
all the way up.
Thank you, sir.
Goodbye.
This town is so quiet.
Hello.
They will not let you take this special piece.
I think we need this for something.
I think we need this purified stone.
I think if we didn't have it...
it wouldn't be good.
A magical stone that wards off evil.
I had to do...
Am I the evil?
I had to do crimes to obtain this.
I might be the evil.
Are there any other coins that we didn't pick up?
I don't think so.
Not that I can remember, at least.
I'm honestly thinking...
of doing the children...
their little...
giving them the...
the strange...
this is also five...
five coins.
Coins.
What's the phrase?
The recital?
What did I say?
Let's see if this is open.
No, it's not open.
Please.
This kid needs his triangle.
Oh, come on.
Let me show you how it's done.
Do you remember...
the 21st night...
of September?
I'm just kidding.
You guys okay?
Watered mysterious flowers.
Triggered war flashbacks.
No.
You guys are so dramatic.
What?
Alright.
I'm doing this, so maybe...
when we go back to the snail...
he'll be complete.
Let's see.
Let's go back to our snail guy.
I honestly don't know if it's...
game progression or what, but...
he deserves his medal.
He deserves it.
Earth, wind and fiber?
You mean fire?
He's so close.
Wait.
Is he done?
Did he make it?
He's basically touching it.
Midnight tonight?
Maybe.
That's right!
There is a coin under there!
I found another one.
I think if I...
can't get...
the kids to play...
Let's just buy the disc.
There's no point.
Otherwise, you know?
What else was in here?
And the idol.
That's right.
Let's just go get the...
Let's just go get the disc instead.
Did you have anything?
The pizza box!
What do we have a pizza box for?
I don't
know.
I don't know.
In the well?
The eternal...
trash can?
The never end...
We have no idea where it goes to.
Wait a second!
I can't use this disc!
Unless...
Let's just buy it.
Because...
I realized...
The gas station is not open.
But I feel like we can still buy it.
What does it say about it?
What could be on this disc?
You just passed the trash can.
I did?
Where?
Oh, there was one.
Let's see if I can throw it away in here.
Nope.
Let's try the well.
Confused!
I'm glad you're not confused about being here!
I think there's six months!
Oh, the boat is on the other side.
What a useless buy.
Well, I guess we didn't buy anything.
But a useless...
time.
Excuse me.
He's still racing, ok.
Still racing, guys.
Still racing.
Dang it!
Oh, that makes me so...
frustrated.
That...
That I didn't get the symbols instead...
or the triangle instead.
We have just a few items.
It's confusing what to do with them, you know?
Break in.
Yeah, right?
Oh my god!
I calmed her down.
Silly grass!
Should we go to the gardener?
Oh my god!
Inserts!
Oh, I don't like this.
Guys?
This area is really spooky.
Read.
May 16, 2001.
Notes on the Supernatural by F.H.
Postma.
I have seen or felt the presence of at least five mysterious spirits.
The tall man, always observant as if chasing a prey.
The short man, it is childlike, reckless, always running about.
The shy figure, invisible and perhaps not harmful.
The gnome, a weaker spirit but should not be underestimated.
The worm, probably a very young spirit.
It is not clear what it wants.
That's the one.
That's the evilest one.
How and why these spirits invaded this town is still a mystery.
I got aware of the existence of magical idols.
They are mystical statues that predate mankind.
Undoubtedly, something must be done with them.
The last pages of the book seem to be torn out.
Don't tell me I'm gonna have to do like...
another...
Oh my gosh!
I think I'm inside his house!
Uh oh.
Isn't this area off limits?
What?
What's in here?
The kitchen.
A bunch of onions!
Why do you have a bunch of onions?
Uh oh.
I'm not supposed to be in here you guys.
Jammed.
Everything is jammed.
The church key!
First, snail.
Then, church.
Guys, we're gaming.
Am I supposed to...
He's still racing.
Okay snail, you're too slow.
I'm sorry.
I tried to get... I tried.
I really did.
Do you think...
Um...
Do you think I need to pacify...
Do you think I need to pacify all five ghosts to...
to...
beat the game though, I wonder.
Because we didn't try with the pizza...
You cannot see the bottom.
Still the same.
Okay.
Get the idols.
I think, yeah, maybe destroying or pacifying each thing gets an idol.
Because we have...
Didn't I get another idol before?
In like a previous... Oh, the short idol.
Yeah, we did get this one.
We got this guy.
And we got...
We only got two idols.
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
Hello?
You cannot make out what they say.
Where are they?
Flower door.
Flower...
What the hell is this?
The altar contains a hole in the shape of a flower.
Oh my god guys, there is still so much more...
going on here.
And there is a ghost in here somewhere.
Somewhere though.
Because it...
It doesn't... It stops shaking.
Like this?
We stay in the realm.
I think.
I think that's what that means.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Flower door.
Can you light the candles?
Oh, let's try.
Let's see if we can.
I can!
Why is this person in here though?
Church is not... not available.
Hmm.
Please, father.
I... I have sinned.
Please let me...
Let me confess my sins.
Please!
I really don't want to do another run through, but like there is...
Still so much we haven't done.
Silly grass!
Locked.
There it is.
Alright guys.
This could be life or death for us.
We have the key.
We have that weird key.
Wherever it is.
The strange key.
It is not of this world.
We already pacified that kid too.
So I guess now is the time.
Can you hammer the flower door?
For some reason, I don't feel like you can.
Check the snail one last time.
No, you can't do it.
Alright snail.
I'm really invested in him.
I'm really invested in that guy, I'll be honest.
I just want the snail to make it, you know.
I just want him to get his prize.
I want him to be a winner.
Come on snail!
We spent 10 coins on this medal.
Oh my god!
I give up.
Alright, let's go.
Maybe there will be the key to the flower door in there.
I don't want to waste too much time.
I'm so close.
Hello?
Oh my god!
Ah, no.
Meet the orb.
That's what this achievement is.
Is it truly you?
You actually managed to find me!
Now that you are finally here, let me introduce myself to you.
I am the owner of the garden you are tending to.
Oh yeah.
I'm really tending to it well.
I've watered the plants and...
Or what is left of me.
My soul got trapped in here by evil spirits!
Who managed to invade our world.
And use this place as some kind of gateway.
I was about to do something about that, but now I am unable to do anything.
You see, the spirits I am talking of present themselves in many forms.
I learned that at least four of them are active here.
Each of their soul is attached to some kind of idol.
Yes!
And the only way to put them to rest is to locate these idols.
And then bring them to the church.
Where these idols reside, I do not know.
But they should be in or near the village.
I hope you are willing to take up this task.
If the spirits do not get stopped...
Then who knows what awaits us all.
I also wonder if...
If Ken ever gets my body back.
I'm going to get my body back.
But that should not be the main priority now.
I suggest you head out of this place.
It might not be safe to linger here.
I wish you all the best of luck.
That's it?
I thought that was going to be an ending.
He said at least four of them.
Two Polaroids on the ground?
Oh, thank you.
A crypt?
Oh, we got the gnome idol.
The crypt.
Something is like flashing in the room.
It's kind of freaking me out.
I can't tell if the game pauses.
I don't think it does when I'm going through my stuff.
I don't think the game pauses.
It's kind of scary.
Flower door?
Crypt?
Trash?
Strange hallway?
Oh, these are the deaths.
Maybe...
When the guy comes up and jumpscares me?
What if I just do this?
Oh my god!
Wait.
Because I was going to try and get the guy that jumpscares me, but clearly that didn't work with the trumpet.
Do, do, do, do, do...
Snail!
Oh my god!
True winner.
Award a golden medal to a true winner.
Wait, what did it say?
This is a proud snail.
That cost me... Wait, what do I get for it?
He won!
That was a cute achievement.
These other guys though...
Let's go to the gardener.
While we can...
Victory lap for the snail.
The snail is number one!
I feel like those T-shirts where it's just like...
I went all the way to...
To this crazy place and all I got was a T-shirt.
Wait, something is on fire?
Guys?
I guess we'll go there in a second.
I'm here!
To pacify you!
The ghost calms down.
Bye bye!
Yeah, I have gotten the worm.
I fed him to the bird.
What is this?
Someone crashed here.
Oh my god!
Wait, what?
How did this happen?
What is this?
Someone lost their cigarette.
Guys, I'm so not sure what to do anymore.
It's time for me to go to bed.
Oh, I'm far from home.
I guess let's just see what happens if...
Nothing happens.
Security dudes!
Wait, what's that?
Oh, that's the guy that died.
Oh my god!
I got the Shy Idol!
Wait!
Oh my god!
I got the Shy Idol!
We need one more.
What?
Do you guys...
Do you think it's the maze?
Because...
There was that guy with the really long head.
I don't want to get jump scared.
You feel safe in here.
Let's just shut this portal door.
But I feel like if I sleep and wake up...
It's Monday.
Yeah.
I didn't finish my duties.
I mean, good enough, right?
Why is it...
Cutting some grass!
What's that sound?
Why does it sound like a sad trumpet?
I just have a little bit left to go!
Don't you worry about it!
We can get this done!
You said... You didn't really give a time by Monday?
It could be like Monday... 3.30?
I can get it done by that time!
You hear a bus honking.
No, no, no!
No!
I didn't finish my duties!
Wait, actually, it looks like we can go whenever we want to.
So, actually...
Can we actually finish this?
Can we actually beat this?
But I don't have enough money.
Ok, let's actually clear the lawn.
How much money will we have after that?
Once I... Once I cut the grass, how much money will I have left?
How much money will I make?
Will I have enough money?
I don't even know!
Doesn't hurt to try.
Yeah, why not?
We are 92% there.
We are actually so close.
93...
95...
We are killing it.
And by it, I mean grass.
Your ass is grass.
I'm gonna cut it.
Probably smells great in here.
Oh, is my vision getting worse or...
Is it getting brighter?
Am I able to see less and less or is it just me?
The
fog...
We are so close.
No, no fog has ever killed anybody except in the fog by Stephen King.
What's that sound?
There is something in the fog.
And it's making noises.
99...
How much grass do I have left?
100% and we got 2 bucks.
4!
Guys, I don't have enough money.
I think there is something in the fog.
The mist is closing in.
Fine.
It cost $10!
Guys...
Bye bye world!
Reach 5 different endings.
I got lost in the mist.
OK, we've read all this.
Sorry snail bro, we gotta save up.
Alright!
Is
it here?
Okey dokey.
I think we can maybe speedrun this a little bit.
Cuz we...
I think we can speedrun this a little bit.
We don't have to do every mission.
We just have to do the essential ones, I think.
Jump scare in 3, 2, 1, BANG!
OK.
Yeah, silly grass.
I'm not gonna go in it though.
I'm not gonna go in the silly grass because I want him to stay there.
For when I get...
When I get...
The stuff, you know what I mean?
The trumpet.
So let's start cutting in here.
Here's a coin since you missed one on the bus.
Oh, that's right!
I did miss one on the bus!
You're right!
I completely forgot about that one.
The one in the back.
I got it in the first game and I forgot about it ever since.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, I've been playing this game for so long now.
Let's speedrun, speedrun guys.
Jump scare in 3, 2, 1...
Do you think he's the other guy I need to...
Oh, wrong way.
The tall idol.
I think it's the guy...
What's his name?
In the maze.
Or...
Do you think it's... Oh, who are you?
Oh.
Do you think it's the scarecrow?
I still have no idea what to do with this corn.
Do I get him when he's tall?
Like when he's... Peeking?
I'm not sure.
Yes, the guy in the maze.
Sorry.
My brain is all over the place right now because I'm like...
Ok, do this part.
Ok, then do this part.
So from here let's go get the trowel.
Over here?
Oh, I forgot to get the bone.
Where was the other bone?
There were two bones.
Her brains are racing as well.
Yeah, I'm gonna try and give the kids their instruments.
Oh, I didn't get the hammer!
I said speedrun, but I'm actually...
I'm not doing so hot, guys.
But here we can get the shidle.
Got him.
It's funny that you actually do have to get the gnome.
To get the gnome idol.
Maybe this game isn't about gardening at all, you guys.
Maybe this game isn't about gardening at all!
Insert joke about six months.
Love me.
Let's see.
Is there a lighter here?
Yes, there is!
There's a...
In the end, there does end up being a lighter.
If you don't get it from the hole.
Pick it up.
There we go.
I thought that might be the case, so...
Something in the area has changed.
And I can light this up.
Oh, just kidding.
Light.
Okay, how much do I got?
I've got two.
But we have a portal to over here.
And I didn't get the bone, because I'm a bone head.
But that's okay.
Let's get this guy.
Our little friend down here.
Sorry.
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Don't shut.
What should be the next step?
I'm gonna cut the hedges so I can get more money.
And then I'm gonna go to the gas station and kill the gnome army.
I wanna kinda hurry up, because...
Atara asked me to be on her stream.
So...
But I was like, oh, I'm streaming.
So right after this, I'm gonna jump on call with her.
So...
I wanna speedrun as much as I can.
We got the travel, so let's dig, dig, dig, dig, dig.
Dig, dig, dig, dig, dig.
How did we get the apple?
Oh, okay.
We need the key to the office for the apple.
To get...
She said you hate her.
She?
Okay.
She didn't ask me to be on her stream.
And then she was just like, hey, when are you coming on my stream?
And I'm like, huh?
That was me earlier when I was checking my...
When I was... Earlier I was just like, wait, I...
I was checking my...
Oh, I got it already.
My DMs.
She was like, when are you coming?
I was like, what do you mean?
She was like, I'm coming on my stream.
I was like...
I mean, I'm happy to do it.
You just didn't ask.
Okay, got all rid of all the mohos.
I'm getting all the trash now.
I'm just collecting money at this point.
So we can get the office key when we go over there.
Cleared all the trash.
Okay.
We at least have enough money for...
The...
Thing.
No!
Her boat is on the other side.
Okay, that's fine.
We have another shortcut.
Oh, let me get the bone too.
You also need the disc.
Yeah, I know.
Let's get the bone so we can pass the dog.
Sorry.
Excuse me.
Thank you.
How are you doing, snail?
I forgot he has a coin.
How many do I have?
Ten!
I should be able to buy both.
Perfect.
Guys, we're killing it.
And I got that already.
Nice, nice.
Good morning, Minto.
Good morning!
We're gaming.
Or a medal for the snail.
So true.
I wonder what the... I know there's probably a death ending with the snail...
Or with the...
With the gnomes.
I wonder if...
I wonder what happens.
Maybe they just start invading the whole town.
There we go.
I still didn't get the plank.
I'm all over the place with this.
Are these the myst...
This has the symbol of the flower door.
Guys, remember that.
I wonder if the mysterious... Watering the mysterious flowers...
Is the key.
I think.
The mysterious flowers are the key.
We'll come back for the compass, because we will need it.
Hi dog.
There you go.
And we need this for the...
For the small idol.
Small idol!
Voice is not...
Not here for...
Singing right now.
Small idol!
Let's go, go, go.
There's a coin.
Did I get the coin here already?
I guess I did.
Small idol.
And I want to get that purifying stone.
Let's get it right now.
I feel like we need this.
Because it's called a purifying stone.
It seems important.
It seems like it could be...
Of some use.
And there's a coin down here.
Hey sad kid.
There you go.
Stupid kid.
Go away small idol.
Thank you.
Grab...
Coin?
How many do we have?
Five!
I think that's enough.
For the...
Compass.
The idol was aggro.
It's okay.
It's because he's small.
He's closer to hell.
Oh the egg ball.
Oh my gosh you're right.
Oh no.
Coin?
Is there any coin in here you think?
Can I rob this mysterious woods?
Anything...
If you're dead can I rob you?
Do you have any coins?
Any coin?
Any coins?
No?
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh whoops wrong way.
Take the bone?
I already got bones.
Guess we'll get another bone.
We read that.
Wait okay so...
Tall man always observe it as if chasing a prey.
Always observe it.
Do you think we just find him randomly then?
We got... Well always running about.
Okay well the short man wasn't always running about.
Maybe it's fine.
And the worm.
Oh shoot I forgot.
Oh my god.
Get me out of here please.
I forgot that the ghost shows up in here.
Is there any things?
Bunch of onions.
Any where to rob?
Any money?
Do you have any money?
You have this rich ass house and you have no money?
Please.
Jammed.
Church key.
We do need that though.
Oh gosh.
Use the stove?
You think so?
To... Wait where is the stove?
Here?
Oh my god.
It's a big empty frying pan.
I don't think I grabbed the corn.
I have to come back.
Oh my gosh.
Scared me.
Okay now...
We put that apple.
Here and we get the worm.
And then we let him eat the worm.
Popcorn?
Wait what do you mean popcorn?
Strange key.
Oh I got the worm back.
That's so funny.
Corn on the stove?
No it's corn on the cob.
I think we might be able to go to the park normally now.
No not yet.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Let's um...
I'm trying to figure out what I want to do.
Oh.
Can the fisherman use the worm?
Oh maybe.
Give it to them.
I gotta go all the way over there though.
I don't think he's there this late.
But we can check.
I gotta get the watering can.
I didn't get that right?
No okay.
Let's go back to the park.
Yeah he's gone.
But we can try.
Tomorrow.
I know there is a...
There's a coin in the gazebo.
In here.
But I don't think I got it.
Nope.
Okay perfect.
How many do we have?
Seven!
Oh my gosh I just need...
Three more.
But I have to buy this.
Oh wait.
I have to buy the egg ball.
What is that sound?
Oh they are cooking.
I think if I...
The tree hole!
Yes!
Oh my gosh thank you.
It was like over here I think.
I think... And then if I cut the grass I should have enough for everything.
After I cut the grass I should be able to buy...
Everything.
Yes.
What...
Else...
Are we doing?
What else are we doing?
Oh watering can thank you guys.
Thank you thank you.
I was like I came over here...
For a reason.
To water mysterious plants.
The bridge is now usable.
Good good good.
Any other mysterious plants around here?
Any mysterious plants?
Did you grab the symbol?
No not yet.
I don't think I even grabbed the plank.
To be honest.
I guess I don't need to fix this bridge.
Actually I probably should in case there is like a...
Chase sequence or something.
To the...
I can't even afford a ticket.
To leave.
Mysterious flower.
Thank you.
Well...
So we'll have to wait for the midnight for the church.
Back towards the church.
Wait was there another one?
Because I imagine...
I imagine that...
The...
Wait.
Oh yeah I did get all the trash didn't I?
I imagine that the mist will not be around if we pacify.
Oh I just was there and I forgot the plank again.
The mist won't happen if we...
Do everything correctly.
Is my guess.
Coin!
Okay.
We are at four.
And the corn.
Okay let's go.
Let's go get those two things.
Corn.
Plank.
How do I get the trumpet again?
Oh I know it was in the gnome area.
I remember.
I'm lost.
Oh my god that lady scared me.
Can you like peek your...Oh there he is.
I did get the corn!
I did get the corn.
Plank.
See?
Maybe I need something else to go with it.
To properly cook it.
Drunk girl?
She's Sunday.
She's not yet.
See?
Like butter or something?
Maybe.
I'm gonna put this plank down.
Like I said we're gonna wait until...
We'll cut grass while we wait.
Until midnight.
I guess.
So we can get enough coins to buy...
The compass.
Oh actually let's go to the gnome area.
And grab the trumpet.
Oh!
I can also...Oh I don't need to do this.
I can water the plants!
It's way easier.
Yeah, watering the flowers will be way easier.
I didn't even get the gnome idol.
I'm like imagining things.
I'm like imagining myself doing stuff and I'm actually not doing it.
I'm getting all my runs mixed up.
It's okay.
We still have to wait until midnight anyway.
Okay.
To grab the plank in the church room.
We gotta open that up anyway too.
What the?
Oh this stupid thing is on.
He never calls me.
Didn't he write like on the thing?
I'll call you if I need something.
Oh I watered all the flowers and that was also a mysterious flower.
Not yet.
You forgot to do that Skelly for the seventh time.
I'm too busy gaming.
I'm sorry.
One more mysterious flower somewhere.
Let's go get the compass.
The door is right over here.
I think we have time.
One compass please.
Thank you.
And to church.
What time is it?
Okay.
45.
Alright, perfect.
Run into the church.
Okay.
We're almost there.
Don't jump scare me please.
I'm running.
I'm going home please.
Please miss.
Don't get me.
Please.
Ghost don't get me.
Nobody get me.
Optimizing.
Good night.
That damn kid.
I'll take your hand.
But I remember.
We went through the maze.
Wait.
Hold on.
The compass.
When we had the compass it led us to the fountain.
The water fountain.
It led us to the water fountain.
We couldn't do anything.
There was a guy there.
Yeah, but it didn't do anything.
I tried watering the water fountain.
That did not work.
I tried my...
I think I tried my...
Trumpet didn't work.
I guess we'll just try... I mean we gotta go back in again.
Hey, where are the kids at?
Hello?
I'm here for the performance.
These lazy children.
Excuse me.
I'm at the park for the children.
It's Sunday.
Yeah, and that's when they perform.
I think the last plant is in this park.
Yeah, I'm kind of like searching around for it as I...
The fish.
What did this do?
Now that I think about it.
It summoned the children!
Here you go.
Your triangle, your trumpet, your cymbals.
I brought back the school band.
Bring the band back together.
Make the school band perform again.
I regret it.
That was it?
Plant near the gas station.
I thought I got that one.
At least I got an achievement for it, I guess.
There seem to be a few optional things.
Near the snail door.
Are they gonna get mad at me for not calming all the...
All the spirits, I wonder.
Since I kept missing that one guy in the gnome room.
Okay, well.
There was some... Oh, here.
You watered all mysterious flowers.
I...
Cause there's stuff like the pizza box we didn't get.
We still have the Polaroid.
I saw a gnome?
I see gnomes?
Oh my gosh.
Flower.
Do you think they're...
Do you think they're good?
No, I don't think so.
I don't think they're good.
I got bad vibes, bad vibes.
Spirits.
I think if I had left with that, they would have attacked me afterwards.
I think they would have killed me while walking out.
Destroy them all.
Money.
Wait, so now that I...
Did that stuff for the kids, I don't think I'm gonna have enough money to buy a ticket to leave.
Let's cut some grass.
We're just 80% of the way there.
82?
Just like real life.
I've given these damn kids my last pennies.
I'm a gardener who's not getting paid.
I'm trying to think of what I need for the water fountain.
If anything...
I mean, obviously I do, but like...
I think the last couple of things I had were like the pizza box.
And the corn.
Not quite sure what to do with that.
Flower gem goes in the church, yes.
And then I imagine it will probably allow me to place the idols.
96.
Almost there.
97.
Wait, did I get over here?
Yeah.
Oh wait, I didn't go to this side over here.
There we go.
100.
We got 2 money.
We're at 5 money.
Maybe we'll get a big bonus if we save the entire world.
You know, if we save our boss from...
dying.
Let's go into the church.
And then we'll go into the maze.
This person is a ghost.
Want help on the maze?
Sure.
You can give me a hint.
Enjoy ghosts!
Thanks for the 20 gifts!
I think we found the crypt.
Is spear mint is green?
What flavor is purple mint?
Grape maybe?
I think the crypt is probably where we, like I said, where we put the idols, so...
Mervy, thanks for the 10 gifts!
Thank you.
Thank you both.
So let's go to the maze.
After you find the fountain guy, all you need is the hammer.
Oh really?
Okay.
I tried that though, because it said it's a delicate fountain.
Maybe I just...
Maybe I'm silly.
Confident feeling.
Yeah, I'm confident.
I don't need to look at anything.
I know where to go.
I go this way.
It's right around the corner!
It's right here!
It's a delicate looking fountain.
Fountain.
Getting my gallbladder removed tomorrow.
Wish me luck.
Obtained all idols.
Good luck, spicy cheese nips!
Why did you get your gallbladder removed for?
I had to kill a guy.
One last thing.
Listen.
You hear nothing.
Am I supposed to hear something?
I thought a coin would come out.
What?
What is that?
Was that the fire?
Did that guy die?
No.
Fisherman.
You gave the worm to the fisherman.
I think I killed the fisherman.
Oh my god.
Should we go?
But we just got all the idols.
Gallstones.
Oh no, I'm so sorry.
Kaguya, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Kaguya!
Happy birthday!
We need save slots.
I know, my gosh.
I want to go, but I feel like I will die.
And I just got all the idols.
What do you guys think?
A worm spirit.
Yeah, let's try it.
Oh my goodness.
Guys, shield your eyes maybe.
Inspect.
The water looks extremely clear.
Nah, I tainted it.
Oh god.
I don't...
I don't know at all.
I think I'm gonna go to the idols.
Idols.
Motion sickness island.
For real though.
Does the M stand for mint?
Do I make you feel sick?
Do I make you feel like that?
Lampy!
Thanks for the gifted.
Thank you.
Yes!
Oh gosh, guys.
Shy idol.
Short idol.
Tall idol.
Gnome idol.
Return all idols to the church!
Guys?
This is a little spooky now.
Hello?
What just happened?
What?
Something is on... Something is on fire!
The whole city is on fire!
I got this.
Ok, I don't got this.
I think it's a little outside of my... my bucket.
I might have to jump in there?
Wait, this door is open.
Oh.
Well, what's the point?
Ok.
In here maybe?
The doors are open!
Oh boy!
The world explosive!
What do you mean?
Oh, hello?
What?
Who are you?
A gardener?
What are you doing here?
You returned the idols to the church?
Why?
It must have tricked you somehow.
These magical artifacts, the idols, together they opened a gateway to this realm...
No!
Metal gear!
The PAL keys!
It will break out and destroy our world!
I can already hear it just outside the house.
You must put an end to it.
There is only one way to stop this.
Quickly, take my key to the attic.
My blessed sword should be boxed up there.
I am unable to move as my soul is taken from me.
So you will have to do this alone.
Strike the demon with my holy blade!
Go now before it's too late!
OK, it doesn't work.
The music is kind of awesome though.
Can I still make that popcorn?
OK, no.
Oh, here.
What is this way though?
Maybe let's check this last door that looks like an attic room.
OK, the blade!
What is that?
Full of mushrooms!
Nothing?
Full of balls!
What is this?
Full of clothing!
We got the blessed sword!
OK.
Full of bounds!
Full of...
Snacks!
Full of chickens!
Save the KFP!
What is through here?
Oh, I don't think we want to go in there.
The purified stone protects you!
We are back in our world!
You actually did it!
Although my soul is still in that other place.
It makes me feel as if I am not really here.
But at least you are still alive.
You can forget about the gardening work.
It's not that important to me anyway.
Thanks for getting my body back here.
You are free to go now.
Just leap through the front gate whenever you like.
Are you going to pay me?
I mean, if you are dead, why can't I have your house?
I still can't afford the bus.
I'm just a broke gardener.
Oh wait!
A key?
What do you mean the key?
All the mysterious stuff is gone.
All the mysterious doorway...
Well, except this one I guess.
Still have this.
Give him a low score on glass door.
Where is the key?
Maybe I go out this way instead.
Reach the good ending!
You brought back the owner of the house.
6 out of 11 endings found.
And we got a cool sword for it too.
Good ending question mark.
I wonder if the good ending is also freeing him, you know?
Winner winner chicken dinner.
How many endings were there?
Oh, it was ending 11, wasn't it?
Or no.
It was ending 11.
We didn't even solve all the Polaroids.
We didn't even collect all the Polaroids.
We didn't even visit all the areas.
We didn't discover all the items.
We met all the characters though.
Wow.
It was ending 11, but it was the 6th ending that I found out of 11 endings.
You think the true ending is after 11-11?
You think it's like 12 out of 11?
Maybe, maybe, maybe.
Surprisingly big game.
A lot going on in this little game.
Groon.
Really unique game.
The looping reminds me of Outer Wilds, but it does its own thing.
Great job tonight, Minto.
Thank you!
I think one ending paid 10 coin bus...
10 coin for the bus to escape from the mist?
Probably that.
Probably like the drowning in that one room where you get to travel.
What else can you die?
The world explode?
Yeah, that's probably a bad ending.
I didn't go into that one room that was like all dark and red.
I'm wondering, I wonder, maybe his body was in there.
Oh, the dog?
Yeah, maybe dying by the dog.
Because he's angry before you give him the bone.
The holy water?
Oh yeah, we don't even know what that was.
The water in that island that we discovered.
Yeah, M Island.
I have no idea.
So mysterious.
That one, I...
I can't even begin to think about.
So many mysteries.
I know, what a fascinating little game.
That was so much fun.
I hope you guys liked it.
I thought it was like a good kind of like spooky not spooky kind of game to do.
Good gardening Minto, never trust a gnome.
So true.
Yeah, it was pretty neat.
Thank you guys for the stream.
I'm gonna head out now.
I'm gonna go talk with Matara, I guess.
Yeah, I'm gonna head out.
And if you wanna play...
If you play this game and figure out what M Island is for, please let me know.
I'm so curious.
So so curious.
And I didn't get all the endings, so...
If you're wanting to see the other areas that we missed and the other endings and the other items that we missed, all that...
Yeah, go for it.
Let me know.
Especially the M Island, I'm so curious.
Matara ending.
No!
Chai Princess, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I like how Eurojuggler at the very beginning of the stream was like, beware the mulch.
And I was like, oh, okay.
There's gonna be something.
You've played this game, there's gonna be something about the mulch.
And then there never was.
Matara Island, cause she makes you sick.
Anyways, I hope you guys liked it.
I had a lot of fun.
I will see you guys tomorrow.
I'm not streaming.
Thursday I'm actually doing a collab with Matara.
We're playing the new Mario game.
It comes out on Thursday.
The new Mario Party game, and we will be playing it.
Mario Party Jamboree.
So yeah, I will be streaming my POV.
So yeah, I will see you then if I see you.
And if not, I'll see you whenever.
Yippee!
Thank you guys!
Otsumito!
Itterasshai!
I'll see you guys later!
Oh, I also wanted to mention.
The stream on Saturday.
I actually didn't plan on streaming that day.
Because I'm going to go see my grandma.
So, the stream on Saturday will be very, very short.
I apologize.
It's just the debut watch-along.
Yeah, the idol EN watch-along.
So, sorry if you're just like, what?
She's only streaming for like an hour?
Yeah.
I wasn't supposed to stream that day actually.
Since I'm going to go see my grandma.
I'll tell you guys how she's doing.
Yeah.
Okay!
Bye bye!
Itterasshai!
Wait.
Before I go...
I want to be...
I want to...
I want to be myself!
Before you go...
Eww!
Okay.
Bye bye.
Yeah, I know you guys didn't want to see me.
Okay, bye.